[Music]
happy international men's day Monday I
usually mutter actually every day is
international men's day but this year
not so much it's over a year since the
start of the me to movement and a
hundred years since women got the vote
I'm not saying women have the power
because that's palpably untrue but there
is evidence men are feelings threatened
when women have a prime seat at the
table and not entirely without reason
Joe Wallace creative director of an ad
agency called JWT reportedly announced
she wanted to obliterate its reputation
for being full of privileged white men
it appears men who questioned what that
meant for their careers was shown the
door and several are understood to be
preparing discrimination claims this
worries me if you attack pale stale
males for things they can't change the
backlash will build men in the
crosshairs will cast themselves as
victims of irrational hysterical cat
ladies we will get nowhere don't let's
enable white straight men to claim they
are a persecuted minority - I'm all for
equality but we have to look hard here
and decide whether the ends justify the
means
I always say this thing right I have not
got enough time on this planet for the
people I love let alone the ones I don't
okay so when I look at this it might
human head on all right with this with
this subject in particular why we even
create in these days
it's gone bonkers it's gone 2018 that's
been the year we we've got to fit into
some group or overall you're gonna be
labeled with this outside nothing
without offending somebody it's bonkers
and basically the thing is all these
people that probably weren't minorities
are now becoming one orys if you beat
some of us stick hard enough eventually
it will begin to hurt and then you'll be
on the other side it's just
I'm throwing as far as I'm concerned and
to be fair it's probably a little bit of
one-upmanship all you've got a ladies
label on Wednesday
I don't care do not mean I'll celebrate
the days I want to celebrate and you can
celebrate the days you want to celebrate
can I ask mad another story that came up
this week was some one bloke decided
that his uni needed a men's officer
several other unis have also decided
they need men's officers what's your
take sure that I can I just quickly
comment on this before yeah right
because I think the reason this day is
needed is because there are some
difficulties that are unique that men
face and are currently for reasons that
relate to the patriarchy as well to use
feminist discourse feel unable to speak
about some of their problems so if you
look at the dire state of male suicide
that really does need to be addressed if
you look at for example 85% of homeless
people are are men and if you look at in
particular 92% of deaths at the
workplace now my father who I recently
posted about because of international
men's day worked all his life in the
desert in the Libyan desert actually as
an engineer and had his face blown off
and all his teeth knocked out and I
remember him coming home one day as a
child and I I literally didn't recognize
him look like an image from Freddy
Krueger his entire face was burnt off in
an explosion what men go through in the
workplace and that's just a mild example
compared to ninety two two percent of
deaths in the workplace are men I think
these are the sorts of issues and
they're not to mention the
under-representation of the white
working-class male versity yeah over
representation of the white working
class male in prison yeah and I just
think these are important topics that we
need to address and if there's a day
that helps us focus on that
Rachel I 100% agree with you on this and
as you know I've been doing a lot of
work in the diversity space recently and
I've written extensively in terms of how
we need to communicate with straight
white men because there is a backlash
there is a resentment that's brewing and
what what we have at the moment is
people don't feel necessarily confident
enough to speak out because of the way
that you sort of shouted down in Mead
but those conversations are being had
behind closed doors and I think you're
right if we don't get this right
particularly with the men and privileged
the experience of privileged white men
is very different to the experience of
white working-class men but if we don't
get this right with the men that have
the most agency in society we are in big
trouble because they can completely put
the kibosh on the Equality Movement
yeah and this has to be collective this
has to be something that we do together
but can I just say in relation to JWT
sorry I'll be quick
my friend is actually in charge of the
whole group and one of the problems that
they had with this particular company
would gender gap pickup yes the gender
pay gap but also because of its under
performance in comparison to other WPP
company so which is why the diversity
was something they wanted to which leads
me neatly to say give you a comment from
a Walter Thompson and I quote it's not
appropriate for us to comment on
individuals in an ongoing process any
redundancies at jate Walter Thompson
London are handled fairly lawfully and
without any form of discrimination and I
just also mentioned the lawyers there's
a question and we of course please then
carry off that but it just it's
appropriate because of that point I
cannot discuss the specifics of the
reported dispute at JWT speaking
generally over the past 12 months or so
a new phenomenon has emerged ordinary
people from a wide variety of employment
are coming to me for advice as they are
feeling targeted simply because they are
whites heterosexual and male this is
happening across multiple sectors
including financial services advertising
higher education and the public sector
it is resulting in a growing distrust of
the diversity industry which was Jim's
point yeah it sorry can I just ask Nick
something this is very interesting
because when can we remember Brett
Kavanaugh
you know the Supreme Court justice who
was accused of assaulting as somebody
when he was a teenager and then there
was the senator who said I've been told
to shut up but I because I'm a white
male from Southern California that's
exactly why I'm not going to shut up now
and people are now saying that bretton
Cavanaugh was appointed because of not
despite of the me2 movement there is a
palpable backlash do you think that's
true Nick or do you think that's rubbish
do you think the white pale stale males
have found
I want to pick up on Phil's point what
has a day ever achieved and if the
situation is as grave as this and some
of the figures that magic quoted are
really horrible as you've got suicide
we should be think about this every day
of every week of every month of every
year we shouldn't just think what anyone
in the middle of November let's also
think about poor blokes who are
committing suicide or sleeping rough on
the streets today
what does point tell me a day can I just
see what that sachindra can I say that
my the point of my debate was not to
debate whether we need an international
men's day it's about the facts whether
if we do not bring men white straight
men young with us you are the three I
know you're on board the bus others will
like that senator from North current
from South Carolina there will be a back
yeah there's a bad clutch because what
is happening as as you say in terms of
even the statement that you just read
out magic what is happening is there are
a lot of people who now feel targeted in
organizations because they are straight
white middle class men but it's the
optics so therefore if you're a group
that feels that at the moment the worst
thing you can be is that even though in
reality we know it's not the case it's
how you but it doesn't matter if you
feel that way you feel that we've got an
interesting quote from Cindy Gulla
who says as soon as we you get equality
men feel oppressed or something what
does she say it's the personal example
of as the saying goes when you are used
to privilege equality feels like
oppression yeah there's also evidence to
show that when women make up 30% of any
organization men think they are overrun
with women also those are limitation for
all men the sweeping side Asia poll
where men are asked whether they feel
their concerns are important or not and
it's here it is do you think issues for
you
men are given more or less priority than
issues for almost 80% of men think they
are neglected and only 57% of women we
have so there is a sense of unless you
are actually you know paying homage and
supporting and enabling these white men
they are going to come back at you
that's right we we fail to listen to
Rachel at our peril that is how we have
a trauma she a ting that Rachel's
commentary you have to go to another
time because it's nearly that's really
it for this week but before we go there
is just time for this we're always
encouraged to be our own biggest fans
but having confidence in yourself isn't
always easy
well Snoop Dogg has shown us this week
that giving yourself a pat on the back
is not a bad thing the u.s. rapper gave
himself some well-deserved thanks after
he was honored with a star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame get ready for a
masterclass in self love from the smooth
Polly
I want to thank me I want to thank me
for believing in me I want to thank me
for doing all this hard work I want to
thank me for having no days off I want
to thank me for for never quitting I'm
gonna thank me for always being a giver
and trying to give more than I receive I
want to thank me for trying to do more
right than wrong I want to thank me for
just being me at all times
so that's why I stooped all straight to
a little do you think he's been
listening to Karen below want to stop it
right there that's all we've got time
for this week but if you want to join in
the debate just search for the pledge on
Facebook or Twitter and thanks for
watching